[Music]
hey you guys
it's
what day is it tuesday
it's work day
working and getting pissed off
that's me every day yeah
[ __ ] super frustrating today
well you know it happens but uh yeah
we got the supplies in for the shirts
we had an order of [ __ ] uh
four shirts and i was gonna send i was
gonna says bees and that's a free shirt
because i got shirts going out to him
anyway they're already made
uh
anyway uh
shot five shirts and [ __ ] two of them
failed
losing money selling these shirts damn
yeah and i don't know what's different
like i don't know what you have three of
them turned out totally fine and then
the other two like the ink just like
washed right out yeah they look good and
then i said i'm gonna wash these just to
be sure
wash them and two of them filled yeah
and i don't know what changed everything
was correct
the only thing i can think of is that i
was didn't have a whole lot of ink
inside the the screen when i was going
through it was trying to economize to
make it easier and faster to clean
and that was the only thing that changed
the next time i'll make sure there's
just plenty of ink in there i figured as
long as the image was on the shirt and
it was cooked it should work
maybe it's got to penetrate through the
fabric a little bit maybe there wasn't
enough to penetrate yeah i mean honestly
i don't think i've ever had that problem
before yeah i mean the ones that i've
made for myself and then i never washed
them when i ship them out
well not usually not usually
but i made them for myself and then
washed them and they came out fine i
don't know if
now i'm [ __ ] scared that we've sold
shirts and that they washed out on
people
i don't know what happened but uh you
know never heard back never never nobody
ever said that
that it washed out but and we've made a
lot for ourselves and we never had that
happen so yeah
and we've done professional jobs where
you [ __ ] did 300 shirts no probably
the most 150 we've done huh
no we did like 80. 80 80. okay been a
long time
willow lee says hello i watch your cat
she's so cute she is she is very cute i
put up the video of her like sitting in
the laundry pile today
uh hey bethina hello from so long being
here been recovering from a heart attack
oh holy [ __ ]
so happy to hear y'all oh my god i'm
fine the grim reaper i mean i'm just i'm
glad you're feeling better i hope you're
feeling better holy [ __ ] that's terrible
but i'm glad we're glad you're here glad
you're back
but yeah
so
the movie we're talking about today
is die monster die it was a great movie
that's a great movie not for everybody
but
i don't know i i quite enjoyed it boris
karloff was in it and it's all british
movie and it's a retelling of a h.p
lovecraft story color out of space yeah
like a loose adaptation loose adapter
but they're all loose every even the
movie well
well not so much i think the recent one
the 2019 was pretty one was pretty close
and there was one that came out in 1987
that was called the curse
um and that one was pretty close
and i think there were a couple like
foreign ones like i think there was a
german one that was like pretty close so
there have been some that are pretty
close there are actually more
adaptations of color out of space than i
knew of until i started looking it up
and actually i had heard the title of
this movie
but i didn't realize until we were like
scrolling through this is on amazon
prime
in the free to me section yeah and um i
didn't even realize that this was an
adaptation of the color out of space
until i read the little synopsis and i
was like oh interesting we should
probably watch that one and you know
boris karloff is in it so win win it's a
good movie yeah it's like i said it's a
very loose adaptation it's like it's not
very long it's only like 79 minutes
something like that i want to say that's
good though like parts of it are kind of
slow and it is like a
i don't know it's kind of a lot
different than the than the story like
it kind of goes in a different direction
i would kind of want to talk about that
a little bit but
um i liked it though to me it reminded
me more not it didn't remind me so much
of like maybe at hp lovecraft story it
reminded me more of like those roger
corman edgar allan poe movies i was
going to say a fall of the house of
ushers kind of like yeah well the the
guy that directed it this was actually
his name is daniel howler and he's this
was his first the movie that he directed
and he actually was the um
he built the sets or designed the sets
for those edgar allen poe
yeah so the quality is good this is a
good quality yeah there was a lot of
like interior i said i'm just watching
the interior decorator porn because i
love that i love those
oh is this 1963 65 65 the special
effects at the end were good for 65.
yeah i mean i thought they were kind of
cool looking yeah
yeah and then the idea that a damn
dude was [ __ ] doing experiments on an
old meteorite that fell from [ __ ]
space giving off down radiation of some
sort they weren't sure what kind of
radiation it was
an american guy involved in it and
everything with a fake gangster accent
was that his real accent
yeah that's nick adams he's american he
was in a [ __ ] ton of uh movies around
this time period i didn't know if that
was a british guy acting you know no i
don't think he's british i'm pretty sure
he's american because i think he was in
a lot of he was in like a lot of 50s 60s
like sci-fi type movies i thought i have
a feeling and i think he was like his
electric rodrick hormone yeah he had a
real kind of stereotypical old-school
like brooklyn style [ __ ] new york
accent it sounded like a damn gangster
well what's interesting about this one
is that i guess because they shot it in
the uk because i mean obviously it's
based on hp lovecraft story and the hp
lovecraft story uh you know being set in
the united states presumably in
massachusetts somewhere um but this they
actually moved it to england so it's
like a town in england called arkham
but then they have like the american
character going over there so
basically okay so what happens in the
movie and i i told tom because i said
it's been a while since i read the color
out of space um so i said i'm gonna
re-read it like before we do the show so
i can remember like all the [ __ ] that
was different because some of the stuff
in the movie i was kind of like oh yeah
that was kind of in the story
but some of the stuff i was like i don't
remember that so
yeah i mean the movie is kind of kind of
a lot different oh um before you go once
you do a plug
oh right right so remember the other day
i said that i had put up a new because i
have that new horror site you guys know
about that scare salon and i showed you
like a shirt that i had made for that
and i also have a new true crime site
which is like a
website which is a bunch of written
content on it and it's going to be a
youtube channel there's only one video
on there so far but i'm putting
another one yeah uh thursday yes so over
there and subscribe to her new channels
you guys will like them yeah but uh i
made i got this mug in the mail today
that i made yeah she made that she's
selling that and it
looks really good in person yeah she
designed that
jenny is a professional graphic designer
worked for all different kinds of
companies and liquor industry people and
club people and [ __ ] i saw that and i
was like that's pretty cool she's like
yeah i made that that looks and that
looks neat yeah i like how show that
again i like how that logo came out yeah
how much is that uh i have no idea you
don't know i don't remember
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty cool probably
more to come too
yeah i've got other stuff on there too
but you know what i mean
uh let's see oh what are you doing
somebody wants to
update some [ __ ] and i was like you
better not update some [ __ ]
right now
uh but yeah so what happens in this
so nick adams plays a guy
what's his name steven steven right yes
stephen reinhardt
and he's an american dude
and he comes to england to arkham
to visit his girlfriend
i guess susan
susan whitley
and susan whitley
lives out at this creepy old house that
has all these gates no trespassing this
means you like bear traps are on the
outside like they absolutely do not want
people coming in there
and so he goes there to visit but
um when he gets there boris karloff who
is the dad his name's nahum which is the
same as the name although the weird
thing about it is that the family in the
story
is they're the gardener family i don't
know why they call them the whitley's
and i was like maybe they're making an
homage to the weightly family from um
the done match horror maybe so maybe
that's what it is because the mom in
this is named leticia
and in double core i think the woman's
name was lavinia waitley yeah so maybe
that's kind of like i mean it's not the
same but maybe that's what they're
imagining i'm not i'm not really sure
but it just seemed weird that they
because in the story they're the
gardener they're just trying to sound
more lovecraftian i guess yeah
oscar says uh watch nope it's easily
jordan peel's best film yeah i've been
wanting to see that actually i remember
yeah i think like you recommended that
uh yes yeah we probably i need to see
that pretty soon i like most of the [ __ ]
that i've seen from him yeah because it
looks pretty cool you'd probably like
get out too actually but i don't quite
understand it but
he does because you haven't seen get out
have you yeah i saw it it was really
good
but um yeah so
so he goes there to visit his girlfriend
uh boris karloff is there looking all
sinister in his wheelchair
and he's basically like the [ __ ] you
doing here and he said uh i'm
met your daughter at the university they
were both at presumably miskatonic
university in the us they don't say that
in the movie but that's what i presumed
uh so they met and apparently they
are gonna run off together or something
like that so she's like well you know
she said to come visit
and he's like yeah no you get the right
this is my house get the [ __ ] out of
here because he just like basically
wandered in like when nobody answered
the door right
so he's like well i can't tell you why
but you you know you don't you know you
don't belong here get the [ __ ] out and
before he even gets there like when he's
in the town everybody in the town when
he says where he's going everybody's
like [ __ ] you or you're not going up
there they wouldn't even like no one
will even take them the dude won't even
rent him a bike
to go up to the house he's gonna walk
all the way i don't know how far it is
but so like he walks across and there's
like the blasted heath and all that just
like from the story but yeah so he gets
to the house and boris carl says get the
[ __ ] out and then like but the then the
girl like comes down susan she's like oh
stephen you're here blah blah and boris
is like okay well [ __ ] i suppose so this
is like i don't even have any control
over me in my own house so there's that
now this the daughter then takes her uh
dick stephen up to see her mom who is
like in
her sick bed and you can't really see
her she's just like behind all these bed
curtains and all this other kind of crap
and basically she says to steven i need
you to get my daughter
the [ __ ] out of here because the bad
shit's going on and then she tells this
story about
this maid
that she had who disappeared like she
started getting some kind of illness
and then disappeared and they don't know
what the hell happened to her so there
was that so the thing about it is that
if you know
what the short story is like you know
you know it's i feel like
i don't have to say spoiler alert
because it's a very very old story and i
feel like a lot of people
have read it
um if you already know like it's a
meteorite that's causing like all these
weird like mutations it's a satanic
meteorite well that's not from that's
not in the story though which is like
that was another thing because
in the movie
yeah they it has kind of like more of a
black magic connotation which like i
said it's not they didn't completely
pull that out of their ass
because this version yeah because that
is kind of more in line with some of
lovecraft's other stuff yeah but these
guys are gods and yeah that don't care
about you in the universe the things
gods that hate you
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i i like the
this movie's take on the [ __ ] color
out of space
around the damn thing where he's got it
he's got [ __ ] baphomet and [ __ ]
devils and demon paintings of it and
[ __ ] satanic symbols and stuff i just
liked it you know it looked good yeah i
liked actually i liked that too i'm just
saying that it's not
it's not exactly like the story like
they do have the thing about the
meteorite and the weird color it's kind
of like green in this case they don't
really go too much into the color being
like a color that you can't describe or
like something that it's just rainbow
prismatic yeah but it's just like this
this like weird green light that like
glows and stuff and did a good job with
the limited with the limited budget and
the limited technology of the time i
thought they did a good job of creeping
you out about something that's fell from
space some kind of
evil meteor
yeah and then mutate life forms and
[ __ ] bring evil [ __ ] and do stuff and
possess you and make monsters make
people into monsters i just thought it
was a cool idea but that's basically
kind of what color out of space was
about
yeah i'm just basically what happened
i'm just saying they did change some
[ __ ] around because
in in this like i said the well in the
story
the character the narrator is never
named
and he just goes
out to wherever this is
um as a surveyor which they actually did
that in the nicolas cage version
where they sent like the surveyor out
but in the story he's like a surveyor
from boston and he's supposed to go up
there and the whole thing about like you
know the blasted heath there's like all
this stuff it's like it looks like a
fire but not exactly like nothing grows
everything's gray and ashy and [ __ ] and
they can't figure out what's the matter
and he goes there and then there's all
kind of like weird rumors about
some strange [ __ ] that's going on like
at this farm and like with this kind of
thing that fell from the sky and the
narrator in the story i don't think he
ever actually goes there like he gets to
the town and then like he talks to this
guy who i think his name is amy pierce
and he's supposed to be crazy but he's
the one that tells him the whole story
about the gardner family and how this
thing fell out of the sky and like all
this crazy [ __ ] started growing and then
everybody started going like insane and
mutating and [ __ ] like that and
so the narrator of the story never
actually goes there he just like hears
this story and he's like nope i'm out
and he like goes right then he just
quits his job and goes back to boston
yeah um that's lovecraft though yeah
it's not he's not really story is not so
much about narrative and story it's more
about atmosphere in fact yeah yeah yeah
the [ __ ]
that's that's kind of
the good part about lovecraft and the
frustrating part of lovecraft
i have the only
story i read from lovecraft
that i remember being kind of like a
coherent story that was modern would
have been mountains of in the mountains
of madness
that one i remember being pretty
like a narrative based story but it had
a lot of weird aspects to it too it
sounds older than it really is
and then a bunch of little tails the
collections that i read when i was a kid
i don't even remember them all
but they're just more atmospheric and
they're not very long
yeah a lot of them are for sure and
nothing really happens in them per se
you're being told something
you know that's
yeah you have to read it to describe it
it's atmosphere more anything else i
always i was always kind of partial to
uh pikmin's model yeah i don't know why
i like that one so much yes but what
he's doing is he's trying to trick your
your imagination into running wild
it does yeah i mean
so i think that's why i love craft is
memorable
is because a lot of half the story is
your imagination filling in gaps yeah
it's implication like like the
implications of it are horrific right
and so what that means is is that
whenever they make a movie based on a
lovecraft story
it could they can the the the movies can
be wildly different from one another but
they still kind of
inspired by the story because when you
read when you read the story a lot of
it's open to your interpretations
well you're filling in gaps because
there's a lot of gaps in the story
i mean look at the movie from 2018
annihilation which was not a direct
adaptation of the color out of space but
i would argue that it has a lot of uh
similarities with the color space
from
i don't remember
everything about lovecraft that i've
read it was a long time ago when i read
it
but i was under the impression or i do
remember saying yeah
this right here is where that movie came
from and
it's it's kind of like it's like
you can't really make a movie
just verbatim from that story you have
to [ __ ] it's implying [ __ ] so you
have to make a story out of this but you
have to read it to understand what i'm
talking about jenny could probably
understand it better than i can because
she's a writer she can explain it better
than i can there's not enough there for
a movie it's not visual it's it's all
literal it's or it's it's literature so
you're
having to fill in a bunch of gaps like a
bible story there's a lot missing
you can get a feel for what something
happened in the jam genesis but it
doesn't verbatim tell you what happened
you know you'd have to
i don't know
i'm letting my mouth run too much
well it's not really healthy what else
is that you're not really helping me
well because you because well because
you never give me a gap to like come in
no way you just keep on talking wait
no i'm just saying that i think that
that's i think that's why like uh
adaptations of lovecraft films are you
know very hit and miss
there's not
as i mean uh considering like how big of
a cultural influence lovecraft has been
um there's not really as many
adaptations of his work as you would
think but i think that's probably why
because his stuff is just so hard to get
a handle on yeah it's very slippery and
it doesn't really like i said a lot of
it is internal a lot of it is based on
your interpretation your imagination
yeah and so like it's and it's hard to
get it on screen because a lot of the
stuff that he puts in the story is not
really described because it's like
because it's too horrible to be
described like
the whole like lovecraftian ethos was
you know
there are some things that mankind like
if you just see a glimpse of it it will
drive you insane because you're right
because it'll break your brain and so
showing that visually yeah is not gonna
work it'd be like trying to make a movie
based on a poem it's it'd be real hard
you know
yeah
camp guys said they're trying to develop
a hollywood movie from mountains of
madison yeah i'm trying to get yammer
del toro has been wanting to do that
forever and i would love to see that
actually because he's a huge huge
lovecraft fan um but it's just i don't
know it just seems like i don't know if
it's ever gonna happen because they're
gonna do it like they need to do it
right the closest movie
to mountain of madness is alien versus
predator that's real close they go up to
the north pole they find an ancient city
old ones and aliens shag offs and
[ __ ] old ones [ __ ] kill people
that's kind of like alien versus
predator that's kind of what happens in
that movie
willow asked if we had seen uh dagon
yeah we actually we talked about that i
think like the other night like on the
side track yeah we're struggling
actually that's one of my favorite
uh lovecraft adaptations
because it's so even though it's like i
said it's called dagon even though it's
actually an adaptation of shadow of
bran's mouth but um still good though
but it's still good and honestly like i
said it's very very slippery and fishy
and it's like that kind of like gave me
the vibe that i got when i was reading a
lot of lovecraft stories lovecraft would
have liked that i think i think it
probably probably he would have liked
that one i think he probably would have
yeah but the okay so the thing about
this one is that
the story goes and i'm not really sure
because i kind of feel like the 2019 uh
color out of space
was a lot closer
to the story
than this one was this one like i said
the guy that came there was like a
suitor i guess or the boyfriend of the
daughter in the story
the original story uh the the family
didn't have a daughter i think they
actually had three sons and all of the
sons went crazy now interestingly one of
the sons was named mervyn and in this
movie they made mervyn like a ma like an
old manservant he was just he was kind
of like
what is it like boris carlos like valet
or butler or something like that he was
the guy that like helped him out and
like pushed his wheelchair around and
stuff his assistant and then like he
ended up dying and like i said i think
too that in the original story
um
you know nahum and
uh you know the wife i don't even know
if they gave the wife a first name she
was just mrs gardner and i can't
remember if they gave her a first name
or not but you know the the meteorite
fell and like all this stuff started
growing and then it started mutating all
the plants and mutating all the animals
and then they discovered that yeah these
big honking tomatoes but you couldn't
eat them like everything was inedible
and then everything started like turning
to ash and gray and like it was you know
it just like [ __ ] up all the lance you
couldn't grow anything else on it and
then the color started making everybody
crazy and like causing all of these like
the whole family was going crazy like
one at a time because they were drinking
the well water like i said they went
more into that in the richard stanley
version like that they made in 2019 with
nicolas cage this one didn't really go
into that and the weird thing about this
is that they actually like because i
guess they wanted to add like a
generational black magic aspect to it
like some of lovecraft's other stories
they actually like took this one back a
generation so that the boris karloff
character nahum he wasn't he was alive
when the meteor fell but it was actually
his dad corbin
who
i guess like the meteor fell and all of
this stuff started growing and corbin
was like woohoo like um you know that's
going to be super awesome like for the
area
and so he
they so they kind of like implied that
he started like talking to some dark
forces like that came with the meteor or
something like i said they tried to like
tie together the whole elder gods and
meteor thing whereas the original story
the colorado space was just more a
straight-up
uh sci-fi story about a meteor that fell
and it had like a weird globule inside
of it that was like a color that mutated
everything and made people go crazy and
made them turn into like melty faced
like freaks and stuff like that so this
so the movie has that aspect to it but
then they tried to like tie in
the whole thing about uh you know boris
karloff and saying oh my father corbin
like was talking to dark forces and he
had the meteorite like in this it's not
even like i think in the story it was in
a well but like in the um in the movie
it's like in this
it's kind of like a well i guess it's
like down in the cellar but it's like
this box that has kind of this lattice
work like over it it was like in a tomb
yeah like a tomb kind of situation you
put it like in a tomb thing but that
yeah so so it's kind of got that and
you're led to assume that the maid that
disappeared she kind of turns up now and
again and she's got veils on and she's
gone crazy and like her face is all
[ __ ] up like [ __ ] anna farnick and
tota and [ __ ]
yeah
and then and then also the mom
the mom leticia who i think in this in
the original story like she like he
locks her like she starts going nuts and
like looking all weird and stuff so he
like locks her in the attic in the movie
she's not locked anywhere she's just
like in confined to her bed i guess and
she doesn't want anybody to see her um
so over the course of the movie she
seems like kind of normal at the
beginning even though you can't really
see what she looks like but then like
later on she uh she mutates and like
flips out and trashes the plays like
keith moon and then like she [ __ ]
uh runs out of her face is all like
[ __ ] lumpy and [ __ ] up to you
um and then
so at the end i actually kind of like
uh
the effect that they did at the end
where
boris karloff because they try to tell
him they're like uh you know nick adams
character stephen he's just like look
this meteor is like has [ __ ] up all
you just like you know it killed your
mate it killed your wife you know it
killed marvin the man servant guy and
it's you know you've got all these
mutated in because he found like all the
mutated plants and animals like in the
greenhouse because he saw like this
weird glow coming out of it so he found
all that he's like look you really need
to get the [ __ ] out of here because you
know it's gonna do the same thing to you
and he's just like no no it'll all be
fine and it's just a rock it's harmless
and he's like yeah you don't really
believe that what the [ __ ] ever but then
like toward the end like boris karloff
he gets he kind of like falls on the
meteor sort of like he's fighting with
the maid who has come back to kill him
like the with the veil dude and then she
ends up it looks like it's edited kind
of weird but like she falls on the
meteor right and like disintegrates she
kind of blows up and it kind of blows up
you just gotta just use you know this is
lovecraftian cosmic horror and [ __ ] just
[ __ ] happens you just accept it she
falls on the meeting with poop
and big old [ __ ] beams of energy come
out and there's like smoldering ruins
and parts of her clothes underneath
there
and then boris karloff somehow kind of
falls in with her and he comes out
glowing and [ __ ] prismatic yeah he
looks like he's into a damn monster he
looks all like silver yeah like he looks
cool i think it's cool and then like
there's a green glow like yeah and all
his hair all his hair gets burned off
and his face gets all [ __ ] silver and
stretched out and i looked and says oh
[ __ ] lovecraft they he the mask that
they had on him looked just like h.p
lovecraft so he's like a glowing hp
lovecraft lumbering around
he looked just like [ __ ] lovecraft
did you notice that
he kind of did to me he looked like i
mean i think he was his ears were
sticking way out i think they were
trying to say that that was the damn
lovecraft mask and the thing about it is
that i don't know if that was actually
boris karloff like underneath or yeah i
think it might have been a stunt man
yeah
but the mask looked like a mask of [ __ ]
like a cheap mask of [ __ ]
hp it didn't kind of it reminded me of
somebody else but i couldn't imagine him
but i couldn't put my finger yeah i
think they were homaging him
now somebody in the comments section
says man uh who was that that said uh
uh yeah
kanak says if if if mountain or if in
the mountains of madness is like avp1 i
gotta check it out well there's no movie
yet you have to read the the book
but no it is kind of like it
uh explorers go they go to antarctica in
the book i think isn't it antarctica
it's the south pole i think so yeah they
go to antarctica and find an alien city
there
and uh
most of the city's huge and uh
the alien city has a lot of [ __ ]
glyphs and statues
and they're doing a study and it kind of
tells the travel these aliens across the
universe and the [ __ ] that they did and
them arriving here actually started like
life on the planet i think uh
and humans evolved from their waste
products and [ __ ] that they were that
they contaminated the planet
and um
they kept humans as pets and they did
all kinds of stuff and
then they got then a big war broke out
between
the old ones they looked like
footballs with tentacles on the bottom
of them and a starfish on the top with a
mouth on it and eyes and big space wings
they could fly they didn't need ships
they could just go through space they
were called the old ones and they'd just
like drift through space forever and
suspended animation they could sleep
and they were real intelligent
scientists and stuff but they had this
race of beings
that they kept as slaves that helped
them build their city and they were
called shag offs
and shag offs were basically what you
saw out of the thing
they were like a big amoeba that could
swallow things up and copy creatures and
[ __ ]
and that's why uh carpenter said that it
was kind of the
the thing is kind of love crafty and
that's a shag off
from h.p lovecraft
same basic story big old amoeba that
could swallow you and cut well the shag
offs swallowed a damn old one and got
the information for a brain and they
became intelligent and spread and shared
the
brain technology between each other and
they overthrew the old ones and then the
and then it turns out the explorers
found out that there's shag out still
running around and old ones running
around in there they woke them up
there's dinosaurs in there dinosaur
carcasses and [ __ ]
but it was kind of like avp1 and the
thing mixed together kinda
it would make a real good movie it'd
make a real good movie
but like somebody mentions there's a in
in that story a lot of the
is them describing what was on the walls
yeah yeah the grit the glyphs and [ __ ]
because there was it's a huge city with
[ __ ] buildings and
statues and
statues of the gods and the statues that
show the the the history of the old ones
and how they went across space and all
the [ __ ] planets that they conquered
and [ __ ]
and it would trip you out back in the
day reading that
it was a story was ahead of its time
lovecraft was was a genius
you know he was a genius he was weird
but
hey well sometimes you got to be weird
to be what the kind of genius he was
yeah we were talking about that the
other day yeah how i don't think his
stories would have been as impactful if
he had been a normal
normal well-adjusted person
some people said well we shouldn't read
him he was racist he was a lot of things
yeah he was racist he was racist against
other white people but that's what made
him weird all right he was he was a man
filled with fear he was very fr he was a
little
kind of was his little he was tall he
was just kind of a bashful shy person
without much exposure to the outside
world and that you when you read his
writing he's very intelligent
he's uh very introspective he's very
kind of paranoid and fear-filled
and worried that the gods don't care
about you that the gods hate you
which you know which that's way ahead of
his time you know what i mean
people didn't write like that
that was like satanic thinking
you know back in those days yeah
but the thing about this movie i was
watching a couple of other um
reviews of it like i said it's not keep
in mind that it's not
a real accurate uh i mean it does have a
lot of similarities with color out of
space the story but it's not exactly
like that they changed a lot of stuff
um like i said it's a little bit slow
um the weird thing i was watching this
one i liked this movie actually i liked
it a lot but i saw one guy that said
he's like the weird thing about this
movie
is that it's like too slow and also too
fast he's like what i mean by that is
that there's a lot of scenes where it's
just somebody like creeping around the
house and nothing really happens he's
like but then it's like only 79 minutes
long and sometimes nick adams who's like
the main like investigator character you
know because he comes there and he's
trying to like get the girlfriend out of
there um like he makes these really big
like leaps of logic that you wouldn't
necessarily make like he figures
everything out without a lot of evidence
you know what i'm saying it was just
made for an audience at the time yeah so
i kind of feel like maybe there was a
few other scenes that had been that were
maybe trimmed out i don't know if that's
true or not but it's like you know what
i mean like he goes to the greenhouse
like it's glowing and then he finds like
little pieces of this meteorite like
planted underneath two like two of the
plants and he's like oh it's under all
the plants and i was just like well
you know i guess maybe you can assume
that but it just seemed like i mean he
figured everything out like super quick
but
you know it's whatever it's i don't know
like i said it's
i really liked it there was just some
kind of it's very much in the it's not
uh you know roger corman it is american
international pictures though so it does
have a lot of that
vibe that the roger corman edgar allan
poe series of movies had
um i don't think it's quite as good as
those but i liked it i don't know there
was just something about it that was
like that i really liked i guess
and i you know it's funny because i'd
never heard
of it i did you know i i knew that there
had been other adaptations of color out
of space
but
i didn't realize there had been so many
like i said i looked it up
and there was this one this i think was
the first one
and uh there was one
i mentioned earlier that was called and
i kind of have to see this now
but there's one called the curse from
1987
uh which is supposedly pretty close to
the actual story will wheaton is in that
and claude aikens and john schneider and
i'm like john schneider from dukes of
hazzard okay i gotta see that uh but
yeah 87 and then there was one although
they said it in the 80s so it's like set
in contemporary times which i'm not sure
i love that but um i kind of want to see
it anyway there was another movie that
came out in 2008 called color from the
dark and that was um set in italy so
that was like an adaptation and then
there was one that came out in 2010
that's called uh defaulb the color uh
that was a german one and uh that's
supposed to be pretty accurate too and
like i said the movie annihilation while
not a direct uh adaptation is actually
like shares a lot of plot points with
the story well not so much plot points
but just the fact that like something
came from space and it's colorful and it
immediately mutates everything like
plants and animals so it has that kind
of like thing to it but it doesn't have
all the thing about like the family and
everybody going crazy and their faces
melting off and all that other kind of
stuff but that is in this movie so i
don't know i i feel like this was maybe
was this maybe one of boris karloff's
last movies he's getting pretty old in
this he's pretty old in this yeah what i
can't did a good job though they cast
him right he was supposed to be an old
man so
yeah he yeah and he's like going around
and he's yeah he's like super sinister
being like creepy and shitty and creepy
like
[ __ ] creeping on people while they're
in bed and [ __ ]
rolling up on them in a damn wheelchair
and [ __ ] doing [ __ ] behind their
backs it's like you creepy old man you
can get your ass whipped doing that
that's right he was gonna kill he was
thinking about killing that because he
he kind of like yeah he went in there
and he was gonna like looking at the kit
was a candle stick right he's just like
i can [ __ ] i can't even
dump that dude on his yeah
but then like the guy was awake though
and he's like overall that old man
overall i thought it was a good
lovecraft based movie you could feel
that there was some lovecraft [ __ ] going
on in it um it's a movie of its time
but uh they did a good job the special
effects and when when it starts going
towards the end part
for the time the special effects were
good um
they didn't spend much money on movies
back then you know they were kind of
like a play something you would see in a
different well especially horror sci-fi
horror sci-fi so you were lucky to get
what you got so i could back in the 60s
i think people would have enjoyed this
yeah and like i said i liked it too i
mean boris karloff is always worth
watching yeah um i really liked like all
the weird green light and i really i
honestly really kind of liked i mean
yeah it looks kind of cheesy by today's
standards but i really kind of liked the
the end scene where he finally gets
taken over yeah by the meteor and then
like he's all silver and it's yeah the
end part where you start getting to the
lovecraftian [ __ ]
the way it's filmed and everything you
can tell that it's british it's because
it feels very much like one of the old
sinbad movies
it looks like sinbad in the eye of the
tiger or sinbad in seven voyage seven
voyages in bad like like that which i
think which is good it's good classic
way of doing special effects it's not
stop motion but the sets and the
lighting and you know the satanic
imagery and [ __ ] i thought it was cool
yeah with all the cause yeah like i said
that's not in the original story but i
kind of like that they sort of added
because i guess they were trying to like
tie it into the larger lovecraft mythos
yeah i suppose yeah they were just
trying to give it a creepy look
you know what's interesting about this
is that
you know on uh amazon prime because like
i said this is a if you have amazon
prime this is on free to me
they also have on there they also have
um the haunted palace which is a roger
corman movie with vincent price in it
and that was a double feature with this
because the haunted palace is also a
lovecraft adaptation so
now i'm kind of like i've been wanting
to watch that anyway but i didn't
realize i was like oh yeah that is a
lovecraft adaptation isn't it so maybe
we should watch that one someday too the
end of this also kind of had a lovecraft
vibe to it
the evil dude is destroyed the meteor
[ __ ] destroys him the entire house
the
the guy and the girl the investigator
and he doesn't save the [ __ ] pretty
girl and they [ __ ] got out of there
and they're standing outside the house
watching it all [ __ ]
burn up in this
[ __ ] fire that created by this
[ __ ] prismatic color that you
couldn't see and i guess well she was
like well i guess this was his destiny
and [ __ ] how the curse and [ __ ] you
know blah blah blah blah blah and the
dude [ __ ] comes out with some cool
[ __ ] lovecraftian type [ __ ] he goes
no it didn't have to be this way this
could have been a great [ __ ] you know
a scientific discovery but he chose to
[ __ ] play this one
he [ __ ] up it didn't have to go down
this way that's not what he said that's
right basically basically
but yeah which i was like when he said
that i was like yeah that is kind of
something you'd read in a [ __ ]
lovecraft book all this bad [ __ ]
happened but it was it was on them it
didn't have to go down that way it was
their fault
they could have done something good with
that stone you tampered yeah
that could have been a great [ __ ]
discovery and now it's gone dumb asses
although i kind of feel like lovecraft
afraid of everything as he was sometimes
he'd say yeah let it lie yeah i kind of
feel like he'd be more inclined to say
like yeah we mankind shouldn't should be
[ __ ] with that because it's that's
going to go horribly wrong right he was
very he seemed like very anti-progress
yeah well it could have been either way
he could because he could have
characters that would say that but then
there'd be an overarching thing of dread
we're like no he's wrong about that
because his whole thing was just kind of
like oh you know man thirsts after
forbidden knowledge but you always it
always like bites you in the ass right
so i kind of feel like that was like the
overall theme of a lot of historically
probably what the movie meant is that
that investigator [ __ ] cause remember
he was saying oh this is radiation just
yeah just causing these animals to
mutate
but what's implied by the story overall
is that it's not radiation
that it's an evil force it's an evil
living force that's satanic
or at least the dude thought it was
satanic he was putting all that satanic
symbolism all about it but it was evil
and it was from another planet
yeah or another place so probably it
shouldn't have been focused shouldn't
have been should have been [ __ ] with
because it was uh it was wiping some
[ __ ] out
know it was probably like decimate the
earth guys yeah you know what i mean
um all right so are we done talking
about it yeah okay yeah all right so
[Laughter]
so tomorrow is our main show
and this should be a good one it's about
the
terracotta army yeah
and we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about that tomb and
everything right yeah that's around okay
yeah that tomb i think is a lot more
those soldiers are quite impressive but
the tomb
complex itself is [ __ ] yeah we'll
talk about the the emperor that had it
built i don't know if they made any
progress on looking inside that
tomb
well i haven't had time yet look at that
yeah do any research yet i guess i
remember back in that thing back in the
late 80s they tried to get a
send a damn camera down in there and
take a picture of it but they were
afraid of allowing oxygen in there
man they
the chinese government won't let anybody
go into the tomb they know it's there
actually would like to see it
hugo said have you seen the 2005 call of
cthulhu movie and did you like it i
don't know which one you're talking
about there was a call of cthulhu didn't
the h uh hp lovecraft appreciation
society make a call
that was like an old black and white one
that looked like a silent movie yeah
that one was excellent i really liked
that one a lot he's talking about that
one and then yeah that was a good one
but i don't know if it was black and
white it was kind of like king kong it
was a silent movie it had music playing
but you know there was no yeah they made
it look like an old silence yeah and
then [ __ ] couture comes out and it's
like it's a claymation
creature it's claymation saw stop motion
i thought that looked great
it looked like something from
lovecraft's time
yeah see which to me
i don't know like yeah you can do
modernized versions of it but i don't
know it's just not the same
i always kind of like associate
lovecraft's stories with that time
period yeah you read that
yeah like around the 1920s so it's just
kind of like to me they seem more love
crafty and
if they're made back in that time period
yeah so you know whatever all right so
be sure to drop by tomorrow evening for
our main show which should be a lot of
fun uh thanks for dropping by today and
we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye